اعتداءات واغماءات على العشب الاخضر
وقطار خارج الملعب اطلق سافرته فسجل هدف
في مرمى وصف بالملعون كان يحرسه حارس عائد
من الموت
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على اقرب مباراه بين
الارجنتين وفرنسا
واي دخلت كل من فرنسا والارجنتين مباراه
صعبه للغايه على ارضيه ملعب جراند في
العاصمه فيديو احداث عده شهدتها هذه
المباراه كان منها شتم لاعبي التانجو من
قبل الجماهير الاوروجوانيه طوال 90 دقيقه
حتى ان بعض الحاضرين قذف اللاعبين بعبوات
المياه وبكل ادوات يملكونها فاصيب لاعبون
واخرون فقدوا وعياهم ما جعل الاتحاد
الارجنتيني يسجل اعتراضه الشديد على
الاحداث لكن ابرز احداث هذه المواجهه
العنيفه هو هذا المرمى فقد شاعت بين
الجماهير اسطوره تتحدث عن السحر واللعنه
حول مرمى ملعب جراند
والسبب اطلالته على طريق السكه الحديد في
بعض سكان هنا يقولون انه كلما مر القطار
وقرر سائقه اطلاق سافره اهتزت الشباك بهدف
المباراه كانت ناريه بمعنى الكلمه حيث ظل
حارس منتخب الديوك وقتها اليكستي بو
متالقا غالبيه وقت المباراه
ويتصدى للكره بشكل رائع رغم انه اصيب
قبلها بايام وكاد يفارق الحياه
ضد المكسيك لكن وبعد يومين فقط تعفى وشارك
في المباراتين التاليتين امام الارجنتين
وتشيلي
لكن تالق الحارس الفرنسي لم يضم طويلا حتى
جاءت ركله حره مباشره من مسافه بعيده ولا
تشكل اي خطر على مرماه
تهيئت الجماهير الارجنتينيه وتساءلت هل
يمر قطار خلف هذا المرمى اثناء تسديد
الكره
عند تسديد لاعب الارجنتيني الركله
المباشره مره قطار خلف مرمى الحارس
الفرنسي اطلق سائق هذا القطار صافره قويه
وبنفس اللحظه سكنت الكره توشيبا
الارجنتين فصافره القطار مع تسديده الوصف
اكدت لدى البعض حينها ان هذا المرمى ملعون
فعلا لدرجه ان روايات تحدثت عن ان عشاق
التانجو اراد واحتضان سائق القطار فرحا
بصافرا التي اطلقها وهزت ارجاء الملعب
وتسببت في انتصار منتخب
[موسيقى]